this isn't the first time david mcgraw's
energy supply has collapsed last year
his old gas firm went into
administration today avro the one he
switched to also ceased trading the real
worry though is not the name of the firm
but the size of the bills previously i
was just about managing now
when i've got to find another 400 pound
per annum i'm going to be struggling
it's getting to the point where
it's not a question of the government
saying the lights will stay on it's i'm
going to be afraid to switch the lights
on
but energy costs are not the only
economic threat coming this winter next
month the government is due to remove
the 20 pounds a week universal credit
rise they've been able to rely on since
the pandemic
in much the same way as the energy
market is facing a perfect storm with
all sorts of different causes leading to
higher prices many families around the
country are also facing a perfect storm
higher energy prices and at the same
time the removal of the universal credit
uplift the government says it will be
way too expensive to leave it in place
it said people should go out and get
jobs but for many families the numbers
simply don't add up
up until three years ago karen had a job
and never thought she'd have to rely on
uc now she's one of millions facing that
cut
the 20 pound uplift going i really
really can't sleep overnight and that is
the truth i just lay there worrying so
much in the past i've had to sell some
of my late mother's jewelry
which she had given me and left me to
give to my children my daughters when
when i passed away and i've had to sell
it because of the fact that you know it
was either that or eight basically that
i mean this is how bad it is whether you
call it a cartoon simply the end of a
temporary boost the impact for people
like karen will be enormous the biggest
overnight reduction in welfare ever
according to figures produced for sky
news by the resolution foundation
families on universal credit are seven
times more likely to face a crisis
paying their bills and debts than others
and low-income households spend by far
the largest share of earnings 7.6 per
cent on fuel bills leaving them
particularly exposed to the energy
crisis nor is it necessarily the case as
one minister claimed that a couple more
hours of work will make good these
shortfalls around two-thirds of people
on universal credit are either already
in work or they're not actually able to
work for instance they are
sick or disabled or maybe caring for
young children so
what's you know what's the government's
plan for these people
sky understands the government is still
set on removing that 20 pounds a week
but is pondering whether to change the
rules so uc claimants could keep more of
their earnings from extra work
but time is running out it is not yet
winter but in economic terms
it is coming
ed conway sky news